first of all you come from New Zealand
guy how old you I'm 15 you're 15 years
old and so much is going on right now
we'll get to the fact the Aryan Deadpool
- in a second the number one movie in
America first thing la what do you make
of this town it's weird it's weird
really duty it's really dirty yeah yeah
yeah we mean it's dirty on the bottom of
your shoe on yours I'm you are from news
so it's very different there right yes
very different like la is green it's
green yeah yeah a lot of trees we have
some green in the lobbies of some of our
hotels we huh yeah it's really different
it's a lot smaller as well yeah there's
like four million people there four
million people in all of New Zealand
yeah there's like more shape than people
so there's more words say something
about it there's more [ __ ] than people
sheep so I thought you said shits and
people well first of all I thought for a
second okay if that's the case why are
you calling our town dirty if there's
more sheep than people there's a lot of
[ __ ] over there
you